right now though Matt Ryan Matthew joins
us live near Sahara and Eastern that
area continues to deal with the impacts
of those strong winds that we forecasted
right
yeah Ted neighbors here blown away and
shocked when they woke up this morning
finding just what's over my shoulder
here when they woke up Envy energy
confirms these are just some of several
power poles knocked down along Atlantic
Avenue here this morning schools send
online DMV appointments rescheduled and
residents with electric wires in their
backyard
see how it's going down Xena cabria
heard a loud thud outside her window
Tuesday night I didn't know what it was
also you know what I
checked
she woke up Wednesday morning Blown Away
by what she saw sending their wires and
you know anything it could shock and it
could like happen like that you know
keeping her two kids trapped inside I
didn't want to come outside and Athena
because of the wires and then you know
the pole how everything's knocked down
and that's also why you know we couldn't
take them to school this morning the
hard overnight winds inflicting a day's
worth of trouble Valley Wide but in this
concentrated area of Winchester it sent
four schools online Wednesday Crews
working to remove power lines that felt
nearly on top of them my sister and I
had an appointment today at 11 45. then
over at the Sahara DMV today's
appointments canceled some waiting
nearly a month for this day let's get
this bad boy back on here this is Pedro
Martinez second time taking off and on
his license plates you've got to be
kidding me after not having the correct
registration paperwork Tuesday I don't
want to waste too much energy and being
pissed because I already wasted plenty
of energy trying to get all the
documents together to get here only to
be disappointed again
now the DMV says it'll honor today's
appointments on a walk-in basis for the
next two weeks NV Energy is still
unclear about how long it'll take to
clean up all that was blown away and no
word from CCSD yet about all those who
were on distance learning today having
to stay distant tomorrow for now
reporting live from Eastern and Sahara
mathie 8 News Now